following in the footsteps of new york
and illinois california has officially
declared a state of emergency because of
the monkey pox outbreak governor newsom
announced the move on monday explaining
that the state of emergency would help
facilitate the state's vaccination drive
as of now he says there is far more
demand for the amongst monkey pox
vaccine than there is supply um
meanwhile and this happened just this
morning president biden
is still of course battling through his
19th bout with kovid but he still
announced his newly assembled monkey pox
response team think of them as sort of
like the avengers except for blisters
robert fenton of fema is now the
national monkey pox coordinator and dr
dmitry daskalakis of the cdc will be his
deputy his robin to his batman i suppose
i know i'm mixing dc and marvel forget
about it it's um
it's a good thing though that we have
both fema and the cdc on the case
because both organizations are
renowned for making every problem worse
and i think their vast experience with
being totally incompetent and useless
will be very important in this case
especially after all
making the problem worse fanning the
flames dumping fuel on the fire would
seem to be the overall sort of
agreed-upon strategy with respect to
monkeybox
for example in san francisco a day
before the virus was declared a
statewide emergency with you know the
lines for the vaccines still stretching
around the corner an annual gay fetish
festival was still held as scheduled
your grandfather
died alone in a nursing home because you
weren't allowed to visit him due to
covid and your kids were locked out of
school for a year but gays in san
francisco were still having their sex
festival
even amid an outbreak that specifically
spreads through those sorts of events in
that community
uh local news outlet reports quote the
annual door alley festival happened
sunday in san francisco's soma
neighborhood despite growing concerns
about the spread of monkey pox the virus
has been predominantly spreading among
gay and bisexual men who make up the
majority of the festival's attendees the
leather and fetish fair draws thousands
of people to san francisco the event
comes after the city just
declared a public health emergency for
monkey pox of the as the virus continues
to spread
i think the viru the risk is not zero
ucsf infectious disease specialist dr
peter chin hong said i think if people
are smart and know how monkey products
is spread they can affor avoid it chin
hong says that the risk of contracting
the virus at events like door alley is
very low
however that risk increases based on
intimate interactions with others
prolonged skin-to-skin contact and
possibly through sexual transmission
although skin-to-skin contact is the
main thing qin hong added so that's
large in terms of medium that will be
prolonged kissing through saliva but it
requires hours
hugging by itself giving a high five
shaking somebody's hand is not going to
result in transmission he says
oh well that's a relief you know if
you're attending the gay fetish carnival
to
give high fives and
shake people's hands then you should be
fine
he assures us
anyway the good news is that the event
was also an educational opportunity the
report continues
uh quote event organizers say they're
working with the city's public health
department to provide on-site outreach
and education despite precautions qin
hong expects to see more cases after
this weekend quote i expect a lot of
activity next week in terms of alerts
qin hong says
so to review this public health expert
and infectious disease specialist says
that the risk of contracting monkey pox
at a fetish festival in a city that's a
monkey pox hot spot is
very low
and yet he anticipates purely by
coincidence more virus
activity directly after the event
concludes
now the san francisco aids foundation
which is a non-profit which has worked
closely with the city's public health
department for decades
they issued their own sort of guide
um for this festival which which they
are calling
douchey's guide to door
with quote some ideas to reduce your
risk and still enjoy your favorite kink
and fetish festival in san francisco
the guide begins quote
we're gearing up for an exciting return
of our favorite street festival in san
francisco up your alley aka door alley
where you'll get your fill of hot hairy
daddies hungry pigs bdsm babes and kinks
of all kinds douchey's got some hot tips
for a fun and filthy weekend free of
anxiety
we are then given a variety of tips and
some of them i can't even read out loud
to you
and really i shouldn't read any of them
out loud but here's one tip it says
take a friend to the dungeon going to
sex parties with people you know and
planning on who you'll hook up with can
be one way to reduce your risk if you're
able to have open and honest
conversations about monkey pox symptoms
and possible exposures
so make sure to have open and honest
conversations in the sex dungeon
they're saying
the guide also cautions that you should
perhaps you know think about avoiding
the piles of gay men having sex with
each other in dark back rooms
and instead stick to having orgies in
well-lit areas also if you appear to be
breaking out
in monkey pox rashes yourself
well then of course the guide says stay
home don't go
just kidding the aids foundation
recommends that you just cover your
bumps with a band-aid and head out onto
the town anyway that's really what it
says
you could actively be breaking out in
monkeybox ah just you know wear long
sleeves put some band-aids on go have go
have fun in the orgy
this is the sort of health advice
that's being dispensed for monkeybox
any warnings or suggestions or policies
more stringent than this
would be shaming to the gay community we
can't have that
that's what california legislator scott
weiner whose name will never stop being
funny recently explained on twitter he
tweeted quote lots of sex shaming of gay
men around monkey pox the same shaming
we saw in 1980s about hiv
lecturing people not to have sex isn't a
public health strategy it didn't stop
hiv it made it worse and it won't stop
monkey pox what will work is vaccination
testing and education
well what about educating people
about the fact that fetish festivals and
orgies are disgusting and barbaric
and are guaranteed to be vectors of all
kinds of diseases
can we educate people about that no we
can't impart that sort of education
because it's simply not a good public
health strategy to tell gay men to make
good health decisions and to encourage
them to please refrain from recklessly
spreading their bodily fluids all over
town yet it was a good public health
strategy to shut down
all of society for a year or more that
was perfectly reasonable practical
to tell people to stay in their homes
and not go anywhere or do anything for
months on end that's reasonable
practical but telling gay men just hey
refrain from the orgies for a couple of
weeks
in fact i made this point in response to
weiner and some guy named lane wood who
has a blue check so again we know he's
important
responded tagging twitter and twitter
ceo he said to me hey twitter safety i
know these are not easy calls to make
and technically matt walsh's tweets
don't cross lines yet i don't care that
he has the views he does he's allowed
however
we know this is paving the path to
violence for his audience
so
i didn't say anything wrong or incorrect
whether factually or morally and i
didn't violate any twitter policies but
lane
wants me banned anyway because somehow
the simple truths i'm discussing might
pave the path to violence
this is of course a common view on the
gay left on friday a gay news site lgbtq
nation published an article
with the headline monkey pox is not a
gay disease but it is being painted that
way worldwide touting the monkey pox
virus as a gay disease endangers both
queer and non-queer people
now to be perfectly clear about this i
don't think
that monkey pox is a gay virus
i doubt it has any particular sexual
orientation at all though i haven't
asked i also don't know its pronouns i
wouldn't presume to assume what i do
know is that it's a disease which
infects gay men nearly exclusively
nearly
in part helped by the fact that gay men
aren't nearly exclusively nearly
the the ones attending fetish festivals
and orgies that's what i do know
two other important points i think
should be made here
first you you notice how often
lgbt people are endangered by the truth
according to the left
you know they they spread this ring of
eggshells around lgbt people and demand
that we walk gingerly on them all the
time
there are a million fantasies false
impressions delusions that we're
supposed to keep intact a million
bubbles we must not burst
this is how the left wants us to see it
anyway
but this approach not only places a
ridiculous unfair burden on all of us
who are forbidden from speaking the
basic truth commanded constantly to lie
but it also harms the very people it's
supposed to protect the truth
that we must shield lgbt people from are
um these these truths are always and in
every case exactly the truths that they
most need to hear
so
who who is the compassionate one the
loving one
is it the guy who shouts to the person
about to walk right off a cliff
attempting to warn him about the plunge
ahead
or is it the guy who tries to muffle the
other guy preventing him from issuing
the warning
which one is loving and compassion
second point
um
there are several reasons why gay people
are allowed rather encouraged actually
to continue running around town having
sex with strangers during monkey box
while the rest of us were made to put
our entire lives on hold during covet
the most obvious reason is that gays are
a protected privileged class and
therefore they have different rules
and they just they live by a different
set of rules and the rest of us do
but there's something else too and and
it's this
the left
believes
that no right is as sacred as the right
to sexual gratification
okay in fact by their doctrines there
really is no right other than the right
to sexual gratification that is that's
that is every right boils down to this
one
the right to be sexually satisfied every
liberty is grounded in this
according to them we have no right to do
anything except satisfy ourselves
sexually
this is by their view in their dreary
miserable vision of the world um this is
what it is there is no meaning to life
other than the pursuit of temporary
carnal pleasure
this is why they can't bear to abstain
or tell others to abstain even amid a
monkey pox outbreak
a life without immediate constant sexual
satisfaction satisfaction is a life
without meaning a life without purpose
it is a kind of death
to tell people to control themselves
sexually for even a day
is to
essentially kill them
that's the way the left looks at it
because this right trumps everything
the right to be sexually satisfied
certainly trumps any concern for safety
or health
especially the safety and health of
other people who themselves have no
worth except so far as they can be used
sexually and discarded
this is what lies at the heart of the
public health approach to monkey pox and
also of course at the heart
of every other insane thing in our
culture
i know you're craving some more matt
wall show content well i have some great
news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com and subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'll see you there